house correspondent john roberts live on
the north lawn good evening john
brad good evening to you time may be
running out for social media companies
to censor content without repercussion
the fcc chairman ajit pai today saying
that he is going to move to clarify
a rule that has so far shielded facebook
twitter and others
this is the president again today vows
to go after social media companies
as he turns up the heat on joe biden
in greenville north carolina today
president trump vowing to keep pushing
the joe and hunter biden email story
despite twitter and facebook moving to
censor postings
that contain email addresses or other
personal information
he's a corrupt politician just remember
it and i'm gonna say it more and more
and and facebook and all can try and
shut us down
but you know what everybody knows it
press secretary kaylee mcinerney's
personal twitter account continues to be
locked
after she posted screen shots of the
emails the trump campaign's team
trump twitter was temporarily blocked
today communications director tim
murtaugh scolding twitter in a statement
saying
this is election interference plain and
simple
president trump again pushing to repeal
section 230 of the communications
decency act
shielding social media companies from
legal action over censorship
we're going to take away their section
230 unless they shape up
north carolina and its 15 electoral
votes were key to president trump's win
in 2016.
a new new york times poll finds joe
biden leading the president by four
points in the tar heel state
the real clear politics average shows
president trump trailing by three points
but that's exactly where he was on
october 15th
four years ago well don't slap too hard
go out and vote we'll clap later
the president again today making an
appeal to suburban women
a key voting group he currently trails
biden with the
suburban women should love trump
president trump also tried to calm
concerns about a recent spike in
coronavirus cases in north carolina
the president touting new treatments and
looming vaccines
and going back to the same well he drew
from six months ago
again insisting the virus will
eventually burn out on its own
it's ending anyway i mean they go crazy
when i say it it's going to peter out
and it's going to end from north
carolina president trump off to miami
the site of tonight's canceled second
presidential debate the president in an
nbc news town hall
at the same time joe biden participates
in a competing town hall on abc
president trump musing on what's in
store for him compared to nbc's recent
town hall
with joe biden i just want to see the
tone
of the way they treated this character
and the way they treat
us sarah complains that by appearing in
competing town halls voters won't get a
chance to watch
both candidates tonight ultimately
bragging rights may go to the candidate
who gets
the best ratings this evening brett
all right john thank you i'll be
watching both i'll be on shannon's show
later tonight with a wrap-up